well blink and either missed them and
frankly i wish i had blinked halfway
harry and meghan debacle touched down in
germany today after a whistled top door
of the uk which they didn't find time to
meet any of their family who all hate
them because they hate them they did
meet a lot of strangers of course and
megan was supposed to be lecturing young
people about equality which is her
favorite subject from her california
mansion but instead she stuck to her
specialist subject the one she currently
really loves which she's talking about
herself
i'm so grateful to be in your company
today i was first invited to be a
counselor at one young world i was
probably a lot like each of you how am i
here and there i was i was the girl from
suits and i was
surrounded by world leaders i was so
overwhelmed by this experience i think i
even saved my little paper place card
proof that i was there i belonged i was
so nervous
i doubted myself and i wondered i wonder
if i was good enough to even be there if
what i was doing in the world albeit
important and meaningful as far as i
thought was it deserving one young world
saw in me
just as i see in you my life had changed
rather significantly
and i was now a mom and i would ask what
is this world he would come to adopt
and what can we do what can i do to make
it better
i don't know what could you do to make
it better you're just so special
and how did you get to sit at the top
table with all the world leaders megan
oh could it be because he married a
british prince and then dragged him out
of his country off to your california
mansion to fleece your royal titles
anyway 54 times you mentioned yourself
in a seven minute speech even i haven't
done that in a speech that gives you
some idea of the scale of the netflix
narcissist um my question really is how
can they be allowed to do this to run
around like a rival royal family
including in this country a country
they've been trashing with a monarchy
they've been trashing with a royal
family they've been trashing
why do we let this happen i want to go
to new york post columnist maureen
keller we've been waiting very patiently
maureen welcome to the show great to
have you on uh you wrote a absolutely
thank you for having me will you write
one of the all-time great tub thumping
extoriating pieces uh about this last
week which i i read on holidays
i thought even i couldn't have written
one quite as savage um so
congratulations but uh tell me what is
it because it's been this kind of
mythology that in america they all love
meghan markle and are proud of her for
coming over here and stealing harry and
so on what is the reality
this is a common misconception that uh
the brits have i understand why and i
can promise you it nothing could be
further from the truth
even you know that that that profile
that i they columned on ran in new york
magazine and it attracted
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
comments immediately now that is a
self-selecting group of woke leftist
self-identified social justice warriors
and they were piling on megan as a liar
as an insufferable narcissist as
completely inauthentic as who does she
think she is she married into this
family all she does is trash them she's
a hypocrite she's trying to monetize her
own children off the backs of the royal
family the ailing queen
so um that piece you know it's it's not
the first time i've written about megan
it certainly won't be the last but that
piece really hit a nerve i mean the
problem maureen is as a country the
united states has now sent two women
to our royal family wallace simpson and
meghan markle the first one led to an
abdication and the second one might be
leading to the end of the monarchy
we need better quality american women
well i think you need anything you need
to sharpen your bs detector a bit
because um
she apparently the royals themselves
caught on pretty quickly that she was
not everything she appeared to be well i
caught on pretty quickly unfortunately i
then got removed from the job that i had
at the time for disbelieving her
nonsense to oprah winfrey what's quite
interesting is the more she talks the
more people realize she is fork tongue
uh grace bakery can you defend this woke
warrior is she the epitome of equality
is she is she the standard bearer you
know how i feel about this i just i just
don't care like you know i find it when
people like meghan markle are held up as
as you say the standard bearers of
feminism and you know social justice
ridiculous because she is obviously so
far removed from the concerns and
troubles of the vast majority of women
and this idea that we have now among you
know certain parts of
the liberal by the way not left or
socialist liberal elements of uh of
politics is that you know we need you
know rich women to like lean in and give
inspirational speeches and kind of show
everyone else how to be but ultimately
it's just the same part of this like
weird cult of celebrity that distracts
people from the real issues that are
affecting their lives and
i mean i'm a republican i don't care
okay i couldn't agree more richard i
thought she'd left the united kingdom
right for privacy and to get away from
the royal family so she didn't have to
go to those sort of charity events that
she went to last night but now she's
back talking about herself and you're
thinking well hang on so are you staging
a comeback as you say is it a rival sort
of royal gig what is going on what is
going honestly what's going on with
harry here i was told on good authority
yesterday that that charles in
particular he's unbelievably hurt by
what is going on with his son and
daughter-in-law he doesn't understand
what he's done wrong he remember he
walked her down down the aisle douglas
let me bring you back in here on this um
there's lots of plays going on here
aren't they with the sussex but the one
i can't get away from they keep trashing
the very institution that gave them
these titles that make them their
millions
there is the ultimate hypocrisy right
there and it's a running soul
well the royal family is clearly just a
leg up for meghan markle who believes
that her position as a duchess now
allows her to
inspire us common folk with her amazing
wisdom unfortunately as we just saw
again from that speech her wisdom is
from the school of hallmark cards-ism uh
it's all um
sort of
sub-obama pseudo-inspiring
stuff about how you can be the person
you meant to be for the being that you
could be and everyone else can be like
you oh it's all totally flannel isn't it
it's total flannel total it's total
final none of it ever makes any sense i
say you mostly see this sort of thing in
hallmark card's philosophy
it's all about you being your true self
and all of this sort of thing
it's it's it i don't think that i mean
i've never heard somebody with more of a
tin ear than meghan markle most people
know the reason she's on the platform is
because she married a princess of course
that's it otherwise she's and by the way
i've seen 24 of suits exactly the minor
roles and when she says she goes little
old me from suits and look at me now
with all the world leaders why do you
think you got there honestly princess
pinocchio i think the queen should strip
the titles i think we're just done with
it or we should just get rid of all the
titles and get rid of the monarchy
is mired in yeah and meghan markle is
you know by far the least of their
problems at the moment i think because
we all know well i certainly wouldn't
equate what they've done with what
andrew did so i agree with you about
that but the damage to the monarchy is
what worries me correct because queen is
in very ill health we know that she's
elderly she's 96 she's not going to be
here for a lot longer we know this what
happens next is hugely important the
monarchy is one of the greatest
foundation assets that this country has
we should be very proud of it and you
know this is catastrophic for the royal
family and they've got to deal with it
they've got to they've got to cauterize
the wound frankly